[Musik]
da im urwald sie sich für mich ein
kulturschock sie sich umarmt sie
manchmal frag ich mich verschwitzt sich
heiß gestochen
es gibt so viele sachen wo ein störer
toter mann muss die westliche
zivilisation und dass das auch nicht
sehen kann anfang und jetzt nachdem
ganze prozess muss ich sage ich liebte
es tolle szene sehne des paradies wo er
immer wieder beschrieben hat das setzen
das kann ich nachempfinden malaysisch
borneo juni 2009 10 der zürcher film
regisseur niklaus hilber und sein
produzent valentin greutert durchqueren
bei tropischer hitze und einer
luftfeuchtigkeit von fast 90 prozent
einen der ältesten urwälder der erde
sie sind bereits tage unterwegs ihr ziel
ein kleines tummelte auf der peene so
nennt sich eines der urvölker auf borneo
niklaus will den bewohnern dort seinen
spielfilm über bruno manser zeigen an
dem er fast zehn jahre lang gearbeitet
hat
warum reißt den richter aus der schweiz
um die halbe welt um einem kleinen
urwald folgsamen wien zu zeigen
lieber ein paar tage früher
das kleine städtchen ist ein letzter
fleck zivilisation am rande dichtesten
dschungel
[Musik]
wir treffen niklausen valentin letzte
vorbereitungen um im dschungel eine
leinwand aufbauen zu können müssen sie
sich zuerst das nötige material besorgen
in einem geschäft für so allerlei kaufen
sie metallbeschläge schrauben werkzeug
und lassen sich holz aus der sägerei
bestellen
die einzige orten wie es diesen film
könnte und das schulden wir ihnen also
das finde ich wie er aber auch vor der
er dass man das macht und von red back
nicht klaus spielfilm handelt vom leben
des basler umweltaktivisten bruno manser
die in den 80er jahren mit den männern
gegen die zerstörung des regenwaldes
gekämpft hat und der seit anfang 2000
verschollen ist der 29 jährige sven
sheikha verkörpert im film ansa
dabei musste er ein großteil der dialog
in penang sprechen lernen
willkürlich die zahlenreihe auswendig
lernt dort habe man sagt das ist sprach
total authentisch töne für sie also bei
also bei flüssen wie unser motto niklaus
wollte seinen film unbedingt vor ort auf
borneo dream mit dem richtigen pin alles
laien wie im film sich selbst verkörpern
geschickt und komisch anfühlt wenn man
das natürlich nicht so abgespeichert
sich im hotelzimmer testen die beiden
das equipment dass sie zum teil hier
gekauft zum teil aus der schweiz
mitgebracht haben
pauli schon
görg schon wieder umziehen
das erlaubt ist gut verspannen das ist
dass er wirklich sein finde ich dass man
statt den urlaub unterbrechen oder so
aber ich danke wind sind ein paar von
niklaus hauptdarstellern treffen ein
sie werden ihn und valentin zur premiere
begleiten man trifft sich zum
gemeinsamen abendessen um die lange und
strapaziöse reise zu besprechen
ebenfalls dazu gekommen ist
produktionsmanager eric und ein pin an
englisch übersetzt
die reise beginnt mit einer
beschwerlichen fahrt auf endlosen
staubtrockenen naturstrassen welche die
holzfäller firmen in den dschungel
geschlagen haben
[Musik]
es geht tief hinein in den urwald zu
penny gould
der pony 2012 kamen gehen von der stimme
der bindung für euro- chefs reis und er
hat damals nur so klappt wie der osten
also direkt vor der bühne taxifahrer hat
systematisch und nicht nimmt es
wunderbar ins normale leben weg dahin
muss gesehen aber die grünen führung
gehen jetzt kurz zu machen ich werde die
latte für screening hoffe dass damit
hoffnung hinter unterdessen kommen
[Musik]
nach sechsstündiger fahrt versperrt
plötzlich eine hütte den weg die pen an
haben sie als blockade direkt auf die
straße gebaut um die holzfäller an der
zerstörung ihres lebensraumes zu hindern
so wie damals mit bruno manser hier
werden niklaus und sein team von bang &
seiner sippe empfangen
[Musik]
niklaus zeigt bang und seinen leuten
fotos von den dreharbeiten längert bruno
selbst gut gekannt erzählt er hätte ihm
damals das blasrohr schießen beigebracht
sie seien zusammen in den wald gegangen
und hätten vögel gejagt
niklaus wird von penns nachbarn in
seiner hütte eingeladen
er möchte ihn unbedingt auch ein paar
fotos zeigen
es sind bilder von seiner familie seine
frau und sein vater sind mittlerweile
beide verstorben wie hat niklaus die
rückkehr zu bringen nach sieben jahren
erlebt zum einspruch falle dass das
jetzt viel weniger familien sind wir
ohnehin einig dass das trauzimmer sie
bei auch familien ex sie sind jetzt sind
es nur grün und anderseits steht mit
größeren einfluss von der moderne war
was ich breit macht und dann ja im
sprachkurse gefunden dass sie eigentlich
gar nicht normalisieren lappert sondern
sind alle das seminar motivierend das
heißt sie ein blauer basis kommt immer
wieder der einzug der hypnose bedauerte
erhöhte jacke
man kann mit den wieder zurück aber sie
sind eigentlich stationär
unterwegs nach einem gitter und zwei
tagen die viel premiere stattfinden soll
warum hat sich nicklaus ausgerechnet
diesen ort wie seine premiere ausgesucht
herum haben seelische wichtige figuren
können
ein später der ziehvater von bruno und
das ist die realität
sie hatten sogar adoptiert gegen das
schloss sie und ich denke ich dass die
beste ordnung hier wo sie prompt machen
die truppe gelangt in einen fluss wo sie
von booten abgeholt wird die sie nach
london bringen sollen
[Musik]
der wasserstand ist niedrig und die
boote laufen immer wieder aufgrund auf
[Musik]
kurz vor long kita werden sie jedoch
unerwartet am ufer abgeladen
und dann sind auf einmal die meisten der
pennern begleiter verschwunden
der grund wird sich später klären
erst mal müssen sie das letzte wegstück
alleine zurücklegen
die finnen wollten den regisseur und
sein team gebührend empfangen deshalb
dass vorauseilen der begleiter sie
werden von jedem einzelnen der
anwesenden begrüßt begleitet von
trommeln und kannst es berührt mich sehr
dass so viele leute aus der ganzen
region den weg auf sich genommen haben
hierher zu kommen
ich weiß wie schwer es ist im dschungel
von einem ort zum anderen zu gelangen
ich fühle mich sehr geehrt und vielen
dank für diesen wundervollen empfangen
das haben wir nicht erwartet
wir sagen nur wie einige weg schlichen
und hatten keine ahnung warum
das war eine große überraschung für uns
es war wundervoll
vielen herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
am nächsten tag beginnen niklaus und
valentin mit den vorbereitungen für die
premiere
die penan helfen tatkräftig mit mit
definitiv selbst spart wie sie reagieren
weil das bild oder film vermittelt muss
natürlich sehen dass das in brunos ist
bildet der film ist über der bruno
manser und wir sind da am grünen sind
sind ihre sicht wie sehr treu
senator vorgestellt
open-air-kino im urlaub das land wien
waren gespannt ist dass es stabile ich
das nicht schwingt das bild ob er jetzt
so weit so gut
aber dann taucht auch noch ein
gravierendes problem auf der
stromgenerator indorf entpuppt sich als
viel zu laut und muss so weit vom
projektor entfernt platziert werden
das waren in den rund 40 meter
verlängerungskabel fehlen
jetzt gilt es im dorf kabel zu finden
keine einfache aufgabe hier draußen im
dschungel
das erste angebot gibt sich als
unbrauchbar
das ist grad kein stromkabel die zeit
drängt die pläne sind bereits mitten in
den festvorbereitungen
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit tragen die bewohner
zusammen was jan kabelreste finden
brauchen doch kein elektriker zu
[Musik]
es funktioniert die verbindung steht
mit dem urwald mourinho nimmt zeichen
fehlen über den schweizer mit dem
publikum
[Musik]
die zuschauer neben im dschungel
kinoplatz einige von ihnen sehen zum
ersten mal in ihrem leben einen film
[Applaus]
willkommen zum ersten longhi kino film
ist die verbindung mit den fingern
diese vorführung ist der endpunkt einer
langen reise von valentin und mir diese
reise war geprägt von vielen erwärmenden
und freudigen elliptischen vor allem
weil die planen sich an der realisierung
dieses projekts beteiligten mit dieser
vorführung ist diese reise zu einem ende
gekommen und valentin und ich übergebe
ich diesen film
in wenigen minuten können wir beginnen
viel vergnügen
[Musik]
über zwei stunden verfolgen die
zuschauer gebannt ihre eigene geschichte
die betroffenheit ist förmlich greifbar
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
kommen wir denn hin begleiten und sie
sind dort fesselte sie und sich
irgendwie als schönste gefühl oder
vielleicht ist ja super er lichtete bin
ich dass nico sprachräume da blitzt im
hintergrund was alles gesagt
jetzt da empfehlen mit ihnen gemein dass
sich ihre geschichte spanischen
geschichte sind sesshaftigkeit zunge
worte und dass sie das so sehen
es ist einfach stark oder sehr mit dem
konfrontiert wurden sind durch das
fehlen und also ich finds setzt sich
mehr als gelohnt nicht sofort wieder
machen bei uns und ich überhaupt keinen
freund
beim gemeinsamen essen sind die meisten
zu beginn stehen in ihren gedanken
der film wird offensichtlich nach dann
erhalten die schauspieler und das team
für die filmvorführung ein geschenk
[Applaus]
später beginnt man sich über den film
auszutauschen
die gespräche dauern bis tief in die
nacht
am nächsten morgen fast niklaus für uns
die gespräche zusammen
die blick zu der jungen generation das
ist sie selbst sind sie geben ihr kleid
im kostüm hergestellt sein und das so
acht uns zuerst eine sehr frauen also
der prägung zum beispiel ganz
interessant zeigt dass sie eine szene
oder bruno der blockade starb szenen
sind hier in ihr hättet der vorne lag
und er könne verhaftet weil das sie
hätten ihn immer im gebüsch versteckt
wurde und er hat jungs das rennen bei
dem jetzt nur zu gut sind empfehlen
wollen
mit bruno derungs gesetz kennt sondern
sehr spannend kunden schönste statement
ich von der frau vom fcf poetisch wann
der film in the head der witz der wellen
lieferungen mit
also schön weiß natürlich waren der film
der pannenhelfer wird ihrem komfort
durch eine offene geschichte
das soll es nun im duo das mit vito
abgeholzt und eine bessere formen und
und toll wäre natürlich wenn man den
film irgendwie auf eine art vielleicht
es bewusst sich auffallend dass den
ihnen dadurch vielleicht das relikt der
wert aber das sind natürlich die
fantasie haben kann
niklaus und sein team machen sich auf
die rückreise
wie die geschichte für die penan
weitergeht ist ungewiss